buenas tardes venía a hablarles de la
lectura del lenguaje de la literatura y
traje unos amigos para para poder hablar
también de parte de ellos el primero que
tenemos aquí es aristóteles y por qué lo
traigo bueno porque aristóteles definió
al ser humano que es lo que vendríamos a
hacer todos nosotros casi como lo
definió por género próximo y diferencia
específica como bien saben los
profesores de filosofía género próximo
porque estamos hablando de que
pertenecemos al género animal hacemos
las cosas que hacen los animales y
diferencias específicas porque en
nuestra justamente en nuestro
diferencial es que podemos pensar es que
podemos razonar entonces aristóteles
dijo que somos un animal racional
que la diferencia con el resto de los
animales es esa del pensamiento y
después de dos mil años
vino cassirer que es otro filósofo del
lenguaje que son las personas en las que
en las que yo me apoyo para intentar
estimular el hábito de la lectura y casi
él dijo que somos un animal es verdad
ha dicho aristóteles que somos un animal
simbólico que podemos simbolizar cosas
que podemos evocar con procesos mentales
de nuestro pensamiento signos y que esos
signos bueno éste tienen un significado
para quien sepa interpretarlos de manera
que también podemos crear símbolos
nuevos y el lenguaje no no nos da la
capacidad de inventar cosas nuevas a
medida que se va construyendo la
historia no por ejemplo hace 20 años
había había palabras que ya están
cayendo en desuso ahora pero sobre todo
no había otras que hemos inventado por
ejemplo de google no google es un
término relativamente nuevo en la
historia de la humanidad de manera que
después de inventar el sustantivo el
sustantivo de origen a un verbo un verbo
que todos conocemos cuando nosotros
buscamos en google qué hacemos
google tuvo que inventar google el
lenguaje ya nos proporcionó la idea de
que sea un sustantivo yo le agrego algo
lo modificó de tal manera que me permite
este el crear el verbo también a partir
de allí nosotros podemos crear un
adjetivo por ejemplo podemos pensar en
todas las cosas que se pueden google que
como serían
serían cosas bucle hables
exactamente eso no existía antes
aristóteles ni cassirer pudieron conocer
nada de eso pero nosotros sí podemos
debido a que el lenguaje es una este no
hablaremos de eso después es como una
una máquina que se reinventa no como un
animal vivo en sí mismo después de para
que se me fueron varios de mis amigos a
ya quería llegar a wittgenstein que es
el que inspira un poco el nombre de esta
charla que es este los límites de tu
lenguaje los límites de mi lenguaje
vick está en decía que los límites de
nuestro lenguaje son los límites de
nuestro mundo y por lo tanto
nosotros tenemos tantas posibilidades
como la que el lenguaje que manejemos
nos dé si tenemos un lenguaje amplio o
ampliado que vamos ampliando en el
correo de nuestras vidas a través de la
lectura oa través de la escritura oa
través de la vivencia o del habla
bueno ese lenguaje nos va a permitir
percibir el mundo y formular un tipo de
conocimiento también más ampliado en
cambio si nosotros manejamos solo un
número restringido de palabras porque o
no leemos o no tenemos el hábito de
hablar frente a los demás o no
discutimos o no posteamos cosas o no
hacemos nada con un lenguaje más sólo
existir y respirar en la concepción
aristotélica seríamos jacques más
animales que racionales no nos gusta
pensar de esa manera la sociedad nos
instruye para que nosotros tomemos a la
herramienta del lenguaje como lo que es
no una herramienta que nos que bueno que
nos mejora
a esta después de wittgenstein el ahí
tenemos a san agustín la idea de traer a
san agustín que vivió hace unos 1.500 ó
1.600 años y es considerado uno de los
padres de la iglesia es que san agustín
utilizó el lenguaje para definir una de
las cosas más extrañas e indefinible que
tenemos en nuestra vida cotidiana que es
el tiempo si yo les preguntara a ustedes
qué cosa es el tiempo como podrían
ustedes definir o conceptualizar la idea
de tiempo que dirían no que se nos
ocurriría y es ciertamente un problema
definirlo porque todos tenemos idea de
lo que es de que es algo como que
transcurre como que tiene un presente y
antes un pasado y después un futuro pero
en realidad qué cosa sería una
definición de tiempo y 'san agustín'
justamente decía eso cuando yo estoy
pensando en el tiempo sé lo que es pero
cuando alguien me lo pregunta ya no lo
sé
y cuántas cosas nosotros nos pasa lo
mismo sabemos lo que son pero cuando nos
preguntan por ellas
no tenemos el lenguaje para designarlas
o para conceptualizar las eso es un
problema del pensamiento y recordando a
dyn que style es uno de los límites que
tiene nuestro pensamiento el límite de
nuestro lenguaje no aquí tenemos ayer
bueno en esta especie de gran imagen que
me gustaba traerlo así giordano bruno
ustedes lo recordarán porque fue un
mártir del bueno no sé si llamarlo de la
ciencia porque en realidad lo que le
pasaba a giordano bruno era que giordano
bruno tenían decisiones o sueños o
revelaciones y hace 400 años cuando lo
mataron éste lo quemaron en el 1600 en
realidad lo quemaron porque él había
visto o en sus sueños o en sus
revelaciones una especie de sueños este
de reales el mundo como una serie de
galaxias una serie de mundos todos
circulando todos en movimientos
orbitales
en realidad cuando el peregrino por
varias iglesias tratando recibir
tratando de que lo recibieran más que
nada y siempre lo echaban de todos lados
al final lo terminaron juzgando bueno
termina con este pero el pequeño
problema de la hoguera pero intuyo el
mundo como como el mundo es sí que es el
mundo bueno y sabemos nosotros que las
intuiciones que había recibido mediante
sus sueños giordano bruno eran eran
acertadas y él las había plasmado en el
lenguaje
tenemos aquí este señor
este señor aún no halla por los mismos
años en los que estaban quemando a
giordano bruno cervantes estaba
escribiendo el quijote y el xj es una de
las primeras novelas donde tanto la
dimensión del espacio como vimos con
giordano bruno y la del tiempo que
habíamos visto con san agustín se reúnen
hay un episodio del quijote que yo
siempre lo estoy contando y re contando
porque me parece que que ofrece una idea
de lo que fue aquella novela en el que
es el episodio digamos de la cueva de
montesinos y por qué esto tiene que ver
con el tiempo y en el espacio por lo
siguiente ustedes saben que con el
quijote siempre andaba sancho en la
vuelta a determinado momento llegan a la
cueva de montesinos y quijote se dice
bueno voy a bajar me voy a estar esta
cuerdita a sancho me meto a la cueva
cuando vos sientas que estoy tironeando
este me suis no todo bien bárbaro el
quijote seattle accord y está en la
cintura se mete sancho se queda ahí
sentado un poco mirando con el burro
a los 89 minutos siente que el tirón y
levanta y saca el quijote de la cueva
y los que leyeron el quijote sabe que
después de eso vienen como dos capítulos
de el quijote en donde el quijote le
cuenta a sancho todo lo que vio en la
cueva de montesinos el funeral los
nobles las peregrinaciones los ejércitos
los animales los días que pasó dentro de
la cueva de montesinos
y sánchez lo queda mirando pero fueron
fue un ratito esto es posible porque en
la ficción y a través del lenguaje
nosotros podemos tras tocar las
dimensiones tanto del espacio como del
tiempo
delmira agustini también utilizó el
lenguaje ghosn todos ustedes saben que
delmira agustini también tuvo una muerte
trágica si es uno de los primeros
femicidios que de los que bueno no sé si
de los primeros y de los famosos en los
que hay registros este fue asesinada por
su cónyuge enrique rey es un episodio
que de principios del siglo 20 pero del
mira utilizó el lenguaje para definir el
amor sí y asociarlo a la vida recuerden
que estamos hablando del lenguaje como
posibilidad que tenemos los seres
humanos para pensar en las cosas más
difíciles no en el tiempo justamente en
el espacio en el amor hay un bonito
soneto de delmira agustini que con esta
voz tan poco privilegiada pero de las
voces a que no era evidentemente de lo
que hablaba carmen hoy bueno eso es esto
dice así si la vida es amor bendita sea
quiero más vida para amar hoy siento que
no valen mil años de la idea lo que un
minuto azul de sentimientos mi corazón
moría triste y lento hoy abre en luz
como una flor feve a la vida brota como
un mar violento donde la mano del amor
golpea hoy partió hacia la noche triste
frías rotas las alas mi melancolía como
una vieja mancha de dolor en la sombra
lejana se deslíe mi vida toda canta besa
ríe mi vida todo es una boca en flor y
esa es la definición de amor que nos
deja del vídeo austin y después tenemos
la imagen de jorge manrique manrique es
anterior incluso a cervantes y otro de
los temas de los que se ocupa siempre
las obras literarias es un tema que nos
interpela tanto como el tiempo tanto
como el espacio tanto como el amor y es
la muerte si ustedes recordarán los que
ya pasaron por el liceo hace un tiempo y
los que lo están haciendo capaz que lo
recuerdan de ahora nomás de estos días
el famoso poema de manrique las copias
por la muerte de su padre este donde
dice entre otras cosas recuerde el alma
dormida avive el seso y despierte
contemplando como se pasa la vida como
se viene la muerte tan callando juan
presto se va el placer como después de
acordado da dolor como a nuestro parecer
cualquiera tiempo pasado fue mejor y
luego dice más rico en esas mismas
coplas nuestras vidas son los ríos que
van a dar a la mar que es el morir allí
van los señoríos derechos hacia acabar y
consumir allí los ríos caudales
medianos y más chicos y llegados son
iguales los que viven por sus manos y
los ricos porque la muerte es para
manrique lo que igual a las personas
tanto los que viven por sus manos como
los ricos van a estar todos unidos en el
mismo destino es muy difícil pensar en
la muerte pensar en el tiempo pensar en
el amor pensar en el espacio sin el
lenguaje y el lenguaje muchas veces
enriquece nuestro conocimiento en
nuestra percepción no esté aquí tenemos
anónimo estoy seguro que algunos de
ustedes me pueden secundar porque
anónimo escribió una cosa en la que se
unen el amor y la muerte que todos
conocemos la versión bellísima del
romance del enamorado y la muerte de
washington carrasco y cristina fernández
el que se anime conmigo a recitar lo por
favor es bienvenido recuerdan cómo
empieza
y está bueno que entre todos podemos
un sueño soñaba la noche
soñaba
mientras
muy más que la nieve fría eso lo dice el
enamorado pero la que entra el enamorado
sigue diciendo como ha centrado amor
como ha centrado mi vida las puertas
están cerradas ventanas y celosías y le
responden
no soy el amor amante soy
hay muerte tan rigurosa déjame vivir un
día
muy deprisa se calzaba más deprisa se
vestía y entre paréntesis dijo que ahí
hay un tema porque si él se calza
primero y después se viste
se le va a complicar bueno pero ya se va
para la calle en donde su amor vivía y
le dice a la muchacha ábreme la puerta
blanca
como te podré yo abrir si la ocasión no
es venida mi padre no fue al palacio mi
madre no está dormido porque se ve que
ellos ya en algún momento
habían habían hecho algo así no
y bueno termina finalmente el explica no
si no me abres esta noche ya no me
abrirás querida la muerte me está
buscando junto a ti vida sería vete bajo
la ventana donde la brava y cosía te
echaré del cordón de seda para que subas
arriba y si el cordón no alcanzará las
trenzas añadiría que entre paréntesis
las trenzas eran el símbolo de la pureza
de la mujer no estoy dispuesta le dice
ella a cortarme hasta el símbolo de mi
pureza para que os pueda subir pero eso
no llega a buen puerto porque la fina
seda se rompe la muerte que allí venía
vamos el enamorado el ahora ya está
cumplida y vieron ustedes que en el
mismo en esos mismos 40 versos que todos
nosotros recordamos o que gran parte de
nosotros recordamos y los tenemos como
grado de fuego están justo el tema del
amor y el tema de la muerte
no quiero bueno algunos conocidos más el
tema de la muerte yo estoy casi seguro
que muchos de ustedes leyeron este libro
sino no leyeron o van a ir a buscar bien
rápido se llama el país de las sombras
largas es un muy bonito libro en dónde
está la imagen de la mejor muerte que yo
haya visto en la literatura este pero el
mejor acto de morir digamos no siempre
estamos con que los héroes mueren
combatiendo el cid o incluso gana en la
literatura del cis gana la última de las
batallas cuando ya está muerto lo meten
en el caballo lo mandan a la guerra y
con su sola presencia el ejército de
este ejército enemigo se va pero en esta
novela en el país de las sombras largas
hay una anciana que muere de una manera
muy conmovedora y se sienta en la nieve
ya vieja
y espera que aquel punto que ve en el
horizonte avance hacia ella aquel punto
que ve en el horizonte es un oso polar
si ella sabe que ya es un lastre para
para su familia que no pueden acarrear
la están acarreando hasta el momento y
espera que el oso polar la maté y la
coma porque después este su hijo va a
matar al oso polar y lo va a comer es
una una idea muy bonita aquí tenemos a
otro personaje pero estoy casi seguro
que este es difícil de que sepamos quién
es salvo qué
este personaje está en la tradición oral
en el lenguaje oral
se llama jose salles y le dicen el dios
verde el dios verde existió le sacaron
esa foto y fue una persona que fue un
comerciante hasta los 60 años y a los 60
años se le reveló dios y él empezó a
predicar un mensaje que era entre el
mensaje de dios y el mensaje que a él se
le ocurría de sus interpretaciones y
entre la década de los 50 y de los 70
según los testimonios que he podido
recabar a través del lenguaje oral y de
los cuentos se lo vio por toda la zona
del litoral era un le decía en el dios
verde porque tenía una capa no esa capa
que lo cubría iba adquiriendo con el
tiempo un tono verdoso pero era tan
señera su figura y era tan esperado que
por ejemplo en un pueblo cercano a san
jose le pidieron que hiciera una
predicción para el pueblo y él dijo que
en ese pueblo cada vez que muriera una
persona iban a morir dos más
entonces los muertos iban a ir de a tres
parece una bobada pero en realidad es
una cosa muy importante porque en ese
pueblo se imaginará usted es que cada
vez que muere uno el resto de las
personas que no son tantas entrar
a pensar cómo es la situación yo me
encontré con estas historias del dios
verde hay otra historia que es buenísima
que no quería dejar de contarse las y es
que entre las dones que se le atribuía
estaba el de convocar a las tormentas
entonces era muy esperado sobre todo en
los tiempos de sequía pero había una
cosa que hacía maravillosa y es que
dejaba embarazada a las mujeres con sólo
mirarla
después de que él se iba de los pueblos
habían muchos casos que se explicaban
obviamente por esta razón
estaban deseando algunas personas que
llegan al pueblo para poder finalmente
todo esto está en la tradición oral
cuando hablamos del lenguaje no estamos
hablando solamente del lenguaje de la
escritura sino también de lo que es el
lenguaje que se transmite boca a oído y
luego boca de nuevo éste es jose
hernandez el lenguaje tiene otra
particularidad que que es la de la
catarsis dice el martín fierro
aquí me pongo a cantar al compás de la
vihuela que el hombre que lo desvela una
perla extraordinaria como el ave
solitaria con el cantar se consuela el
lenguaje es para todos nosotros un gran
consuelo muy amables
[Aplausos]